um
yeah another thing about about mk ultra
is they like all the studies they did on
the prisoners like whitey bulger
yeah apparently like what's the story
with him and mk ultra
well the government admitted after he
died
that's when it came out i can't remember
who i think was a journalist or
something
or maybe it was during his trial i
thought he was like
openly talking about it yeah he was
talking about but nobody would believe
it
but during his trial i think it was his
lawyers were able to get his prison
records
and somebody sent them to me recently
where they have the dates that he's
given lsd
and this was all in the 50s you know
before manson was in prison but
in the 50s he was still a kid he didn't
well he got out of prison in
67-32 so 57 he would have been 22.
um he was in the same prisons that were
treating people like bulger
experimentally with lsd
so one of the jurors who convicted
whitey bulger reached out to me when my
book came out and she's gotten a lot of
national
attention she didn't know that there was
a little bit of mention in the trial but
the judge wouldn't let too much of it in
after he was convicted he started
writing her
and telling her all about the
experiments and she
is a very good reporter she's not a
journalist but she lives in boston
and she started looking into it working
with researchers
and found out that it was much more
extensive than anybody ever knew
and could have been the reason he became
such a violent so
sociopath uh it was when he was very
young
yeah that happened and then when he said
he became a notorious killer after
and that entire time being protected by
the government he was a federal
informant
you know and um well with two agents who
the the fbi denies that anybody but the
agents knew that
he wasn't that they weren't they were
rogue agents that were
paying him to get information and
provoking him and stuff
so she wanted me to write a book with
her and i just said i can't do something
just on whitey but keep coming to me
with your information and all
so we've been sharing information since
i haven't talked to her for a few months
so i don't know if she found another
author but yeah
whitey bulger had what happened to i
believe manson
in prison on paper i don't have a record
yet like she got
but i'm working with some people now
trying to get records from when he was
in prison and they won't release them
because they say their medical records
but he's a convicted dead notorious
criminal so i've got i actually have a
lot of work to do i have to find out how
they got the medical records of whitey i
think i think was because whitey was
alive and white he shared him and he had
access to his own records
but i don't think i'm ever going to get
the rest of the records from
if you read in the book it took me like
two years to get the records i did get
from the bureau of prisons about manson
and the
at trial when he was convicted his
defense attorney was trying to get his
prison record and they wouldn't release
it to him
and this was during the death penalty
phase of the trial and when i
talked to experts about that they said
they can't anything should be allowed to
be introduced when somebody's life is at
stake
so the state was arguing for manson and
the others to be
you know executed irving canaric the
defense attorney wanted to show
that manson had always been a docile
prisoner
had never been badly behaved in prison
never been violent
and he couldn't believe that this the
government that u.s government wouldn't
release the record
and he screamed and hollered and since
this
the
the trial was such a circus and irving
kinetic was pretty crazy too
nobody took him seriously and it wasn't
i talk about it in my book
the attorney general in 1971 john
mitchell who ended up going to his
prison himself for being part of nixon's
cabinet and part of the plumbers and
stuff you know
in the mid to late 70s he sent a
representative
of the department of justice who worked
beneath him to argue to the judge
against releasing manson's file i can't
find evidence of that having any other
case in the history but i believe that's
just like the watson tapes
there's secrets in there about what was
going on with manson's head and what
they were doing to it
that they're never going to share wow so
the record i got
was i think 70 pages out of
probably 300 or 400. they described it
one of the kineric got somebody to
describe what the parole record looked
like
and i think they said it was like two
phone books thick
and i got like that much
so who was his parole officer before he
went in for the seven years
well that was interesting the parole
officer who violated
him in 19 so he got
he got convicted for the stealing the
the uh the the letter in the um yeah the
mailbox
the mailbox yeah uh and that was a
10-year sentence
and he was released i think after two
years
on parole and then within a month or two
he didn't show up for a parole hearing
not a parole hearing
an appointment with his parole officer
they immediately
violated him sent federal marshals to
texas
who went into mexico where they had
information that he was in mexico
the mexicans turned them over to the
marshals at the border of laredo and
texas they don't do that for these
small-time criminals
and then they brought him back to l.a
and then he was sent to due to the next
eight years
of his prison sentence which would have
taken him i think to 69 or 70.
but then they decided to release him two
years early in 67 so he could go and do
what he did
but what's so ironic and you'll i
mentioned this in the book
he got sent back to prison from missing
one appointment
one meeting you know you're supposed to
go either once a week or once a month
roger smith when he was his parole
officer
he wouldn't show up for meetings and
then when he was down in la for months
at a time and he was never violated
he was getting arrested for rape for
drug possession
for uh pimping during 67-69
charges dropped every time in my book i
have a scene where i take this record
that i got and what few pages they
released to me
um you know the prisons and to this
retired district attorney named lewis
watneck
and van nuys and is he the judge he was
a judge yeah right okay so he had been
he had been a d.a and then he became
a judge and uh i think was van nuys
and then he retired and he was sick and
dying and he's like on a
oxygen machine so he's raspy but i had a
tape recorder
and he's going through my documents and
he actually
manson had come before him when he was a
judge on some petty charge
and he said i dismissed him on that case
i remember because there was no evidence
but
it was something like breaking into a
car or something
but he remembered very well but then he
was looking he said i had no idea
and he said there's something this is
this is chicken [ __ ] this is all chicken
[ __ ] yeah
and i'm like what's chicken [ __ ] he goes
well you know obviously people make
mistakes
we're a bureaucratic system but this is
like almost on
other every other week he's getting
picked up taken in
booked and then released without charges
all of these are violations of his
parole he should have been sent back
10 different times on the stuff you're
showing me
but he also should have been prosecuted
on half of these things and they just
dropped the charge dropped the charge he
goes
somebody wanted him out he was more
valuable to people
outside than inside somebody worked to
keep him
out on the street like he was an
informant i said i said you mean like an
informant he goes
well people confuse what an informant is
an informant doesn't just
provide information sometimes
and there's a history of it they can
provoke other criminals to commit
crimes they can conspire with them and
then walk away
and then the police know what's going to
happen right before it happens they can
be much more proactive
so he said you to me he goes you got to
find out
who he was working for i go how am i
going to find that because i don't know
you're the journalist and i go well who
do you think it was
he goes well i'd start with the los
angeles sheriff's office then go to the
lapd he goes they're not going to tell
you but that's who you should look at
and i goes that he goes no dea
[Music]
fbi he didn't say the cia
but he said it could have been any
number of agencies
who he was sh either sharing information
was sharing
something with and they wanted it to
keep going but there's no way
this is an anomaly like just a couple
mistakes he goes this is a pattern
there's no way we would have missed this
whoa and what was important about him
was he you know he was
in law enforcement you know from the
prosecution side and then as a judge
during that same period so you know a
lot of times if i show it to somebody
now
they'd say of course you should have
been picked up we have computers but you
didn't so
he was important because he knew exactly
how they
shared information how it came in and
even
roger smith's relationship with manson
his parole officer for the first year
while he became charlie manson you know
he came out of prison
he was panhandling playing guitar in the
bay area
gets hooked up with roger and within a
couple months has this following of
women you know the first six months i
think he had anywhere from
four or five to ten women that were
following him all over the bay area
going to the clinic he would leave the
women with the doctors
to get tested you know for vd and get
some of them were pregnant get pregnancy
attention and he going to meet with uh
roger for his parole hearings
and everybody you know they described it
to me i'm not the first one to report it
they said
the women would follow manson they never
stood beside him they always had to be
behind him
they wouldn't spoke unless he spoke to
them first they would pick things up for
him they were like slaves
how did he become this guru in a few
months how did he develop the skill to
all of a sudden have
these people do whatever he said and
then within two years
do whatever he said including go kill
some strangers in the house that you've
never been to before except for tax
right and do it you know with as much
you know brutality as imaginable and
then come back and not even be
remorseful
about it um so
that's the kind of thing that you know
the book
shows what was basically withheld from
the public and that's what booliosi did
you know he wrote the best-selling true
crime book of all time
and held her skeleton skelter yeah that
to this day you can
probably go into any bookstore yeah even
if you google like
charles manson documentary or book
there's also there's also a documentary
called helter skelter
well no there's two scripted movies okay
so the movie
the first one that was made in 70 the
book came out in 74 i think and then the
first
tv movie it was a two-night movie which
they didn't do back then it was like a
big event
i think was 76 and to that at that point
it was a highest rated tv movie
in the history of television it took one
and two spot i think number
one number one was the second part and
number two was the first
then he remade it in uh the early 2000s
he updated i mean it was the exact same
story but it was
right new actors you know juliose's
narrative believes he's narrative again
yeah
and then you know in my book they'll see
it opens with our confrontation
my confrontation with vince in his
kitchen where he's threatening me and
right trying to stop the book and
writing to my uh publisher and calling
me at all hours of the night
i